[Music]
okay everybody so i
am super super excited today because
i am joined by pa ola lazaro
aka juanita sanchez aka princess
how are you doing today i'm doing great
steve
um how are you oh i'm doing good yeah
and i i was just so
pumped for this finale after the whole
wait with the pandemic going
on and it did not disappoint and i've
just
loved watching you bring this character
from the comics to life as a comic
reader
myself it's been really exciting and
you've been killing it
so much i appreciate that no problem so
what i wanted to ask you though is
this is such a huge part on a huge show
can you kind of
give me how this kind of came about was
it a competitive process did you have to
audition
um yes if i did have to audition
and you know i've worked on like a
couple different shows um and then this
audition came up for
what they call in the industry of self
take which is the casting director
is actually california and i was in new
york so you just had a tape of the
audition and
and uh as soon as i read the sides for
the character
i just fell in love with her and i just
saw the heart her big heart behind
her defense mechanisms of comedy and
loudness and all that stuff i just saw
her vulnerability in her heart and
i sent the tape in and then i got a call
back and then it was a waiting process
and
yes it is it is i think competitive i
mean i i don't like to see it like that
but it is uh i don't know i was just
praying
and hoping that i would get it because i
really fell in love with the role
no and that's so amazing that you did
and
i i have to just as a fan just watching
i wonder too because you seem so
passionate about it which is great for
the fans to see
especially how you're engaging with the
fans and posting about on instagram and
twitter
and can you give me from someone who is
excited
and clearly grateful that you have this
part and appreciative can you give me
the feeling you got like the
first day you put on the outfit you got
the purple hair you're around this cast
and crew
this big stage like were you feeling
nerves what was going on in your head
oh my god if you could see my face right
now it's like beaming
this huge smile because as soon as i
i mean when i even when i got the call
that i got it
i fell to my knees and i just started
crying wow
um and then when i when i got to where
the clothes for the first time i was
like a seven-year-old
getting a new bike for christmas it was
it was bad type of excitement
of when we're kids and and we get what
we've been hoping for
that doesn't happen very often when
we're adults but
it became that childish excitement of
what could be
the future and getting to play a comic
book character and this
comic book character is just like my
seven-year-old
little girl is just jumping up and down
and
when i put the clothes it was just like
ah i couldn't i couldn't stop smiling
oh man that that is so awesome and you
can see just
you're you're bringing it here as the
character and
i wonder you do such a good job of
finding a balance of keeping the
character like princess but not
too cartoonish or comic-esque-like which
is really important on screen so
was this a conscious effort on your part
and like how do you find that balance
i mean it is a conscious effort but it's
also like i start thinking about
people and who i know that are big like
that and
and have big loud personalities and i'm
sure
you know people like that and usually
those people
you know i try to think of one of my
best friends and and he's like that
and he usually those people don't really
care
about other people's opinions of them
and that's why they get they get to be
so free and open
and people who are not like that look at
that and they're like oh man like
this person's so free and and courageous
and
so for me you know it's the balance of
sticking it
with that courage and that vulnerability
and then obviously putting it in the
context of the world
of the apocalypse of what is going on in
the
story you know yeah and it's interesting
you say that because
you're comparing it to like friends you
know that have those big personalities
so
what i wonder is how much of princess
kind of relates
to you
okay okay um i mean you know
i've said this before but i think
princess is very similar to
me when i was a kid you know and i was
hyper
and and you know i'm much more i'm much
calmer now but uh but
but i was a hyper kid and
i like singing and like running around
and making people laugh
and performing and i don't know i just
wanted to enjoy my life and
i think i draw a lot of who princess is
and what she represents
from that inner child of mine
and yeah definitely definitely their
similarities
so it's interesting too because when you
first jump on the screen you know we
find out you've been alone
in this city for like a year by yourself
so
as an actress what mindset do you have
to get in to find
juanita here and like how do you get
there like you know what i mean
yeah i mean i think i again i think i
just tuned in with that excitement
with that same excitement of getting the
role i i
tuned into that excitement when i saw
unico and
eugene and ezekiel i
i mean we're all living through kind of
a
similar situation than princess because
we haven't
really because of quarantine and because
of safety measures we haven't really
been seeing
you know a lot of our relatives and our
friends so
but obviously this was shot before that
happened
but i think i just tuned into that
excitement that childish excitement
of what could be you know sure what
could be
and and how exciting it was for her to
see people again like
big personalities uh thrive when they
have
people around them and if not they
become very
introverted and solitary and also
maybe they go to rather dark places
you know yeah and so she would go ahead
no no i was just going to say to your
point about the dark places like
she seems like she's in a dark place
especially the episode where they're you
know she's walking through the mine
field
and she has this really important line
to the gang that
she was told once that she's hard to
love and never
had any like real friends so can you
kind of explain though
in that context like maybe how she's
viewing
her own image to this crew and why she
is she feeling insecure there around
them
i think she's just realizing that she
needs to drop her
her walls and her defense mechanisms of
comedy and
and being big in that moment i think she
realizes like
okay it's time to drop that let me just
be honest with them and see if that
works because
obviously not being honest is not
working
um so i i think that's when she switches
gears
and and is actually transparent and
herself and says listen
i've been alone and it's not it's
actually not different from
before the apocalypse and this is why
i am the way i am and i'm sorry but this
is who i am
you know yeah so yeah so i think she
switches gears
and turns to honesty because her lack of
honesty was clearly not
successful of course no and
it's interesting too because you see
she's already got some really good
writing about her character and that
she's more complicated than it looks on
the surface
and right and again her appearance i
love they just stayed so true to the
comics with what you're wearing
and i love your instagram posts where
you say
you call the jacket the sofa can you
explain that
well um it's just it's just so
big and so fluffy and comfy but
that it it literally feels like i'm
putting a piece of furniture on like
i i i feel like it's like my little pink
sofa and
my little face place so you're one of
the lucky ones where you don't have to
have a bunch of heavy makeup on and you
you actually like uncomfortable what
you're wearing oh yes i mean then again
when i was shooting that it was october
so
it wasn't that hot so let's see what
happens next season
when i have to shoot in the middle of
summer
i love that um so before i let you go i
you know have to bring up the end of
that crazy finale where you guys are
surrounded by what looks like
stormtroopers
uh can you right kind of can you give us
a hint maybe into what we might see
in princesses like story arc or maybe
what she might become as a person a
little bit i think you know
from what i understand i think we're
gonna get to know her
a lot more and know a lot more of her
backstory
but that's about all i know so far which
is super exciting
yeah and i mean you must be so excited
you're going to be on the ride for this
big final season like this must be
surreal tv
oh man i'm super excited steve
um everybody's just so welcoming and so
kind and
and i'm just thankful to be a part of
this family and
and the fans are just amazing
and dedicated and yeah i'm just
very excited for this i speak for the
walking dead fans in saying that you are
killing it as princess you're bringing
such great justice and respect to the
comic character
and i cannot wait to see what you bring
to the table
in the season finale so everyone please
check out the walking dead now if you
already haven't it's on amc
premiere amc on demand and it's
replaying on abc
as well and you can catch up to the show
or re-watch if you want on netflix so
paola thank you so much for joining me
and i hope to talk to you for season 11.
thank you so much steve i had a blast
with you please stay safe
and thank you so much